it's great to welcome back to the
program johann hari who is a writer and
journalist whose latest book is stolen
focus why you can't pay attention and
how to think deeply again johan always
great speaking with you hey david i've
sent you before we went on air it's
really weird whenever i talk to you
because you're like a voice in my head
that i listen to so much that it always
feels slightly surreal when i'm then
interacting with that voice but it's
lovely to be with you always always good
to talk to you and this is a really
timely book um
we first should start with
what is the case to be made for this
lack of attention and lack of focus
because there are some who say this is a
very popular story to talk about but
there's really no evidence that there is
a focus or attention problem at this
point in time so first question is how
do we quantify that this really is a
problem i used to say exactly what those
people say that you know every
generation struggles with attention and
nothing unusual is happening now
and i started to write stolen focus
because
i noticed that something really weird
seemed to be happening to my own
attention with each year that passed
things that required deep focus like
reading a book having deep conversations
watching a long movie things that are
very deep to my sense of self were
getting harder and harder they were
getting more and more like running up a
down escalator you know what i mean like
i could still do them but they were
getting harder and i told myself well
this is just aging right but then
i was particularly worried about a lot
of the young people in my life
a lot of whom seem to be kind of
whirring at the speed of snapchat where
nothing still or serious could touch
them and i decided okay i'm going to
look into the science of this i'm going
to use my training in the social
sciences at cambridge university to
investigate this to see what's happening
and even very early on some of the facts
about this were quite startling the
typical american office worker now
focuses on only one task for only three
minutes for every one child who was
identified with serious attention
problems when i was seven there's now
a hundred children who've been
identified with that problem so i want
to understand of course there's many
complicating factors going on there i
want to understand what could be
happening so i went on a really big
journey all over the world i researched
this for three years ain't the leading
experts on focus and attention from
moscow to miami to melbourne over 200 of
them and did a really deep dive into
their research and what i learned from
them is that there's scientific evidence
for 12 factors that can make your
attention better or can make it worse
and loads of the factors that can make
your attention worse have been
significantly rising in recent years
let's give a real no sherlock obvious
example we sleep 20 less than we did a
century ago and sleep is essential for
focus and attention when you're sleeping
your brain is repairing it's cleaning
itself it's healing if you don't do that
your brain is literally clogged up and
it's harder to pay attention dr charles
seisler arguably the leading expert on
sleep in the world he's at harvard
medical school said to me even if
nothing else had changed even if the
only thing that had changed is that we
sleep so much less than we did in the
recent past that alone would be causing
a very serious attention crisis but
actually there's many factors beyond
that and what i learned is when you look
at these bigger factors what you realize
is
your attention didn't collapse
your attention's been stolen from you by
these very big and powerful forces and
once you understand that it opens up a
very different set of ways that together
we can begin to get our brains back one
of the ones that's often mentioned is
very generally
social media and i think that that's
just not really precise enough from the
research i've done and tell me if this
coincides with the research you did
really what's that issue in a lot of
these things and it's particularly
notable with social media is
rapidly changing focus from one topic to
another
uh rapid fire and that that creates the
expectation of that continuing and it
makes it it's sort of like you're you're
not exercising the muscle of thinking
and focusing on one thing for an
extended period of time is that the
underlying reason why the social media
piece is often mentioned
i think you've as you saw often do david
you you brilliantly honed in on a more
complex and nuanced thing you're
absolutely right we tend to think of it
as oh it's just social media did this to
us the
the answer is much more complicated and
you've gone to one aspect of the
complication so to
talk first about that one that you've
just raised which is really important
this started to become clear for me when
i went to mit to interview one of the
leading neuroscientists in the world a
man named professor earl miller and he
said to me look there's one thing you've
got to understand about the human brain
more than anything else
you can only consciously think about one
or two things at the same time
that's it this is a fundamental
limitation of the human brain it has not
changed in 40 000 years
it's not going to change on any time
scale any of us are going to see you can
only think about one or two things at a
time
but what's happened is we've fallen from
mass delusion the average american
teenager
now believes they can follow six or
seven forms of media at the same time so
what scientists do and there's an
enormous amount of research on this is
they get people into labs younger and
older people and they get them to think
they're doing more than one thing at a
time and what they discover is
invariably you're not doing more than
one thing at a time what you're doing is
you're juggling very rapidly between
tasks you're juggling from one thing to
another to another and it turns out when
you do that it always incurs a cost a
psychological cost called the technical
term for it is the switch cost effect so
when you try and do more than one thing
at a time you will do
all the things you're trying to do less
competently you'll make more mistakes
you'll remember less of what you do
you'll be less creative and i remember
when professor miller first explained
that to me obviously i then did a huge
amount of research into the literature
on this
thinking okay i sort of get that but
this must be a small effect
the evidence is quite shocking on this
i'll give you an example of one very
small study that's backed by a wider
body of evidence hewlett packard the
printer company got a scientist in to
study their workforce and this scientist
split some of their workers into two
groups and one group was told just get
on with your task whatever it is and you
won't be interrupted and the second
group was told get on with your task
whatever it is and you're going to have
to also answer a heavy load of email and
phone calls so basically the way most of
us live now
and at the end of it they gave an iq
test to both groups the group that had
not been interrupted
scored on average
10 iq points higher than the group that
had been interrupted give you a sense of
how big that is if you and me got stoned
together now david if we smoked a fat
spliff our iqs would go down in the
short term by five points right so being
chronically interrupted is twice as bad
at least in the short term as a debate
about the longer term for cannabis um
than being chronically distracted well
to give you another study there's one
study that found just receiving eight
text messages in an hour
reduces your brain power for the main
thing you're trying to focus on by 30
i would argue most of us are losing that
30 most of the time that's why professor
miller said to me at the moment we're
living in what he called a perfect storm
of cognitive degradation as a result of
all these interruptions to what degree
is this sort of like you know you stop
lifting weights for a while and you lose
the muscle but then you can pick it back
you know assuming your health is
suitable for it you pick the weights
back up and you get the muscle back to
what degree is all of this a question of
the right habits and practices that can
be regained and to what degree does it
not seem that way so the evidence on
this is pretty clear you can get a
little bit better at it but not much
right there's just a limit to what your
brain can do like professor miller said
this is just a fundamental limitation
some people are slightly better than
others if you really put effort in you
can get slightly better but the switch
cost effect is that you know as
professor miller puts it a textbook
level truism right oh no no no so i
don't mean the switch i mean developing
the focus again developing the focus
again yeah
sorry i misunderstood yeah your answer
is more scary in that context well yeah
i'm sorry
there is a huge number of things we can
do to get our focus on okay um and i
think we've got to tackle this at two
levels right with all of the 12 causes
that are damaging our attention and
focus which includes some aspects of our
technology but go way beyond it from the
food we eat to the hours we work there's
a huge array of factors that are pouring
acid on our attention but
in terms of whether it gets better i
think this for all of these factors with
one exception there's two levels of
which we've got to respond so the first
is personal there are all i think of it
as sort of defense and offense right
there are all sorts of things we can do
to defend ourselves and our children
from these factors that are embedding
our attention and i go through dozens of
them if you think about switching
switching which is one of the causes um
give you an example you can't see this
because it's behind my laptop but in the
corner over there i have something
called a k-safe i promise you i'm not
getting commercial sponsorship for these
guys i keep plugging them a case safe is
a plastic safe you take off the lid you
put in your phone you put on the lid you
turn the dial and it will lock away your
phone between for between five minutes
and a whole day yes i will not sit down
and watch a film with my partner unless
we both imprison our phones i won't have
dinner with my friends unless we all
imprison our phones so that's one
example of dozens that i give of a
personal intervention but i want to be
really honest with people and i think
your audience is unusually well fit
fitted to understand this point
these individual tweaks are hugely
important i'm passionately in favor of
them they will really help
but they will only get you so far
because this is a systemic problem right
at the moment
it's like someone is pouring itching
powder over us all day
and then they're leaning forward and
going hey buddy you might want to learn
how to meditate then you wouldn't
scratch so much so which logical
responses screw you i'll learn to
meditate but we need to stop you
destroying my you know pouring this
itching powder right right right the way
professor joel nigg one of the leading
experts on children's attention problems
put it to me is we're currently living
he said we need to ask if we're
currently living in what we call an
attentional pathogenic environment an
environment in which everyone's
attention is being degraded or pretty
much everyone's and if that's the case
then the primary set of solutions we
have to pursue are environmental we have
to together as a movement take on the
forces that are doing this to us yeah
when i've spoken to cal newport about
this and you know his his concept is
that of deep work
and you know he talks about at the
individual level
maybe when you're actually doing work
that's not email based you don't have
your email open in another window that's
like a that's one thing but if your
employer expects that you're responding
to emails within 10 minutes then it's
not really something that at the
personal level is going to set you up
for success no you've put that
brilliantly and there is a collective
solution to this that i've seen in
practice this is why i'm profound
although kalaniport is a good writer it
gives good advice i'm very uncomfortable
with a lot of this because
a lot of it like
my case safe right that i mentioned the
thing that imprisons my phone i use that
for four hours a day and i'm conscious
that when a lot of people hear that
they're going to go well screw you i
can't do that right
how could i possibly do that that's not
a kind liberating piece of self-help
advice that's a taunt to people i can't
do it so there's a solution to this in
france in 2018 they had a big crisis of
what they called la burn out which i
don't think i need to translate and the
french government under pressure from
labour unions and they would never have
done it without pressure from organized
labor set up a government inquiry to
figure out what the hell's going on why
is everyone so burned out and one of the
things they discovered is that 35
of french workers felt they could never
stop checking their phones or checking
their email when they were awake because
their boss could message them at any
time of the day or night and if they
didn't answer they'd be in trouble right
so i can give them all the lovely cal
newport advice in the world they can't
do it right they just can't do it so
the french government again a stress
labor union pressure was crucial
introduced a legal reform it's called
the right to disconnect
every french worker now has two rights
your work hours have to be defined in
your contract and you have the legal
right to never answer your phone or
check your email when you're when your
um work hours are over so it's paris
obviously before the plague to interview
people about this you know when i was
there rent a kill the pest control
company was fined 70 000 euros for
trying to get one of their workers to
check his email an hour after he left
work now you can see how and there are
dozens of these collective reforms we
need to fight for you can see how that's
a collective reform that sets people
free to make the individual reforms that
many of them want to make and there's
dozens of these collector reforms
whether it's dealing with the food
industry
because the food we are eating at the
moment is profoundly damaging our focus
and attention or whether it's dealing
with the specific aspects of our
technology which is not all of our
technology and it's not inherent to our
technology that are damaging our
attention and so i argue in the book
that just like we needed and of course
still need a feminist movement for women
to reclaim their bodies and their lives
i argue we need an attention movement to
reclaim our minds and it requires a big
shift in focus because at the moment
what i did when i couldn't pay attention
is i blamed myself i was saying wrong
with me right why am i not strong enough
why isn't my willpower good enough but
when you realize this is happening this
is a systemic problem a structural
problem that requires systemic solutions
you realize what's the only thing that
solves systemic problems it's movements
we need an attention movement to reclaim
our minds and i would argue it requires
a shift in consciousness
we are not medieval peasants begging at
the court of king zuckerberg for a few
little crumbs of attention from his
table we are the free citizens of
democracies and we own our own minds and
we can take them back if we want to and
i'm conscious that can sound a bit fancy
or grand eloquent i'll give you a very
concrete example of a precedent for this
in american history that has improved
the attention of every single person
listening to your podcast or watching
this
in i think you're a little bit younger
than me david but i can just remember it
used to be completely normal it was the
standard form that people used leaded
gasoline in their petrol uh in their
cars right
a bit before my time it was completely
normal that people painted their homes
with leaded pain right and it was
discovered in the 1920s that this
profoundly damaged people's brains and
it particularly damaged children's
ability to focus and pay attention but
for years and years the lead industry
funded a kind of
pseudo pseudo-scientific denialist wing
of science that denied this but by the
1970s the evidence was completely
overwhelming the exposure to lead was
profoundly damaging children's brains
and the lead industry funded funded a
whole campaign saying well the problem
is people just don't duck housewives
don't dust their homes enough
encouraging people to dust enough turns
out dusting doesn't deal with lead
exposure so what happened a movement of
ordinary moms it was overwhelmingly moms
banded together and said
why are we tolerating this why are we
allowing a for-profit industry to damage
our children's brains this is this is
crazy we can't permit this and so they
banded together and it's important to
see what they didn't demand
they didn't say
let's ban all paint
they didn't say let's fan or gasoline
they said let's ban the specific
component that is damaging people our
kids focus and attention they succeeded
as a result the center for disease
control says the average american child
is three to five iq points higher than
they would have been had lead not been
banned so that's an example of a
collective movement identified something
in the environment that was damaging our
attention ordinary citizens banded
together fought it and succeeded so what
i go through in the book are these 12
factors that are damaging our focus and
attention now where we've got to follow
the example of those moms and get them
out of our environment um in the very
limited time we have left johann the two
to three and sometimes four hour podcast
format has grown quite a bit in the in
the last few years um
how does that i mean is that related to
what you're talking about in that i mean
listen it's a different type of focus to
listen to a three-hour podcast or the
specifics of how people consuming it
really where the sort of detail where
the devil is and it doesn't really deal
with this attention thing
no i think it's an example in the same
way that you can see that whole foods is
a counter movement to the obesity crisis
right you have an obesity crisis because
our food supply system has completely
changed that's profoundly damaging our
focus and attention it's also causing
obesity in fact has caused obesity for
me at several points in my life
and of course that means that you then
get a subsection of the population who
are privileged uh who can then go to
whole foods right um and that's great
now we're lucky because long form
podcasts are free so you don't need as
much privilege so i think it's
absolutely true when you create an
environment uh which is where you know
the average office worker is switching
tasks every three minutes that creates a
tremendous hunger for greater depth and
the thing we've lost with attention this
attention crisis is depth i would just
say to anyone watching and listening
think about anything you've ever
achieved in your life that you're proud
of whether it's starting a business
running a campaign group being a good
parent learning to play the guitar
whatever it is that thing that you're
proud of required a huge amount of focus
and attention and when focus and
attention break down your ability to
solve your problems and achieve your
goals also breaks down and that creates
a tremendous hunger for greater depth
greater engagement and of course
long-form podcasts are a beautiful
example of deeper i mean i seem to have
been on every long-form podcast in the
world in the last week so i was like
losing my voice the the the these deeper
conversations are what we're desperate
for in the same way that we're desperate
for nutrition in our diets we just don't
know how to get it so i think you're
you're absolutely right and i think that
analogy with the obesity crisis is is
really important because
i think we are now with where we are we
are now with attention where we were
with obesity and say 1970 right you were
beginning to see the beginnings of a
disastrous trend and people responded by
blaming themselves just buying diet
books and it was a disaster it didn't
work because it wasn't happening because
individuals failed it was happening
because the whole system failed which is
why we've got to deal with the system
we've got to deal with the factors that
are destroying our ability to focus and
pay attention and i believe i learned
for stolen focus exactly how we can do
that i went to places that had done it
from new zealand to france we can
absolutely win this but we're gonna have
to fight for our attention the book is
stolen focus why you can't pay attention
and how to think deeply again we've been
speaking with the book's author johann
hari johann always great having you on i
really appreciate it ah it's totally a
pleasure david i meant to say on my
publishers tase me that people can also
get the audio book if they want to from
any audio book site i'm also meant to
say you can get it from good book stores
but i always feel like saying well you
can also get it from shitty bookstores
if you want to there's no rule about
this right but yeah thank you such a joy
to be with you david thanks so much